so in the last video I talked about
vector fields and here I want to talk
about a special circumstance where they
come up so imagine that we're sitting in
the coordinate plane and that I draw for
you a whole bunch of little droplets
droplets of water and then these are
going to start flowing in some way how
would you describe this flow
mathematically so at every given point
the particles are moving in some
different way over here they're kind of
moving down and to the left here they're
moving kind of quickly up over here
they're moving more slowly down so what
you might want to do is assign a vector
to every single point in space and a
common attribute of the way that fluids
flow this isn't necessarily obvious but
the if you look at a given point in
space let's say like right here every
time that a particle passes through it
it's with roughly the same velocity so
you might think over time that velocity
would change and sometimes it does a lot
of times there's some fluid flow where
it depends on time but for many cases
you can just say at this point in space
whatever particle is going through it
it'll have this velocity vector so over
here they might be pretty like high
upwards whereas here it's kind of a
smaller vector downwards even though and
here I'll play the animation a little
bit a little bit more here and if you
imagine doing this it all of the
different points in space and assigning
a vector to describe the motion of each
fluid particle at each different point
what you end up getting is a vector
field so this here is a little bit of a
cleaner drawing than what I have and as
I mentioned in the last video it's
common for these vectors not to be drawn
to scale but to all have the same length
just to get a sense of direction and
here you can see each particle is
flowing roughly along that vector so
whatever one it's closest to it's moving
in that direction and this is not just a
really good way of understanding fluid
flow but it goes the other way around
it's a really good way of understanding
vector fields themselves so sometimes
you might just be given some new vector
field and to get a feel for what it's
all about how to interpret it what
special properties it might have it's
actually helpful even if it's not meant
to represent a fluid to imagine that it
does and think of all the particles and
think of how they would move along
for example this this particular one as
you as you play the animation as you let
the particles move along the vectors
there's no change in the density and no
point to a bunch of particles go inward
or a bunch of particles go outward it
stays kind of constant and that turns
out to have a a certain mathematical
significance down the road you'll see
this later on as we study a certain
concept called divergence and over here
you see this vector field and you might
want to understand what it's all about
and it's kind of helpful to think of a
fluid that that pushes outward from
everywhere and it's kind of decreasing
in density around the center and that
also has a certain mathematical
significance and it might also lead you
to ask certain other questions like if
you look at the fluid flow that we
started with in this video you might ask
a couple questions about it like it
seems to be rotating around some points
in this case counterclockwise but it's
rotating clockwise around other still
does that have any kind of mathematical
significance does the fact that there
seemed to be the same number of
particles roughly in this area but
they're slowly spilling out there what
does that imply for the function that
represents this whole vector field and
you'll see a lot of this later on
especially when I talk about divergence
and curl but here I just wanted to give
a little a little warm-up to that as
we're just visualizing multivariable
functions